[Musique]
l'équitation de tradition française a
été inscrite au patrimoine culturel
immatériel de l'Unesco en 2011 le Cadre
Noir de Saumur c'est l'harmonie entre le
cheval et l'homme entre l'homme et le
cheval et d'ailleurs la statue est-ce
que c'est un homme ou est-ce que c'est
un cheval la question est légitime la
question se pose l'équitation de
tradition française c'est une école de
conduite de soi de respect et d'écoute
ce qui me mène à la rencontre de Patrick
Lescuyer l'un des lignes héritiers de
cette institution mais est-ce que c'est
un homme ou un cheval du coup
[Musique]
c'est Patrick ça va ça va ouais il
s'appelle comment déjà
18 ans elle a fait quasiment toute sa
carrière pour faire des gala c'était une
jument qui était extrêmement pointue
dans son métier et en fait on a décidé
il y a quelques mois avec les clients en
chef que aujourd'hui il était temps
qu'elle aille faire des poulains
pour aller faire des bébés c'était le
recruteur un peu toi je dirais le
détecteur de talent il faut détecter
chez un jeune cheval tout ce potentiel
et il doit pouvoir remplir toutes les
missions c'est-à-dire la mission sport
ensuite pour la formation pour les
présentations cadre noir et puis
quatrième mission c'est la recherche on
cherche à trouver avec nos scientifiques
du bien-être voir comment on peut
améliorer leurs conditions de vie faire
en sorte que tout l'impact du matériel
ah oui elle aime bien marcher au contact
du Cadre Noir je commence à comprendre
alors comment tu fais pour déceler le
potentiel de l'animal dans un premier
temps je l'observe au box est-ce que
c'est un cheval qui est plutôt confiant
avec l'homme ça c'est tout le côté
mental au box ensuite l'aspect physique
sportif en liberté ou monter quand tu
mets ta tête devant moi on ne voit pas
c'est mon émission quand même je sais
que tu es plus belle que moi
tu restes à côté de moi
oui oui mais c'est bien comme ça allez
allez
hypnose épique
hypnose nous sommes issus d'une longue
tradition équestre le cadre noir c'est
200 ans c'est 18 ans 15 Cordier ensuite
c'est les premiers galas ensuite c'était
le corps des enseignants militaires et
ensuite civil et militaire et
aujourd'hui on perpétue la tradition et
vraiment notre rôle c'est un rôle de
transmission de formateur d'éducateurs
que ce soit avec nos jeunes stagiaires
que ce soit avec le public et puis
ensuite tout le côté recherche ou en
fait on essaie de mettre en avant les
nouvelles pratiques c'est à dire que le
cadre noir il s'inspire toujours du
présent on essaie toujours de rester
dans le modernisme et c'est ce qui fait
qu'on a toujours de la trait le cadre
noir ne s'est jamais ternie
et donc l'espace d'un instant je suis
devenu aussi blanc que le cheval je te
jure quelles sont les qualités requises
pour être
complètement posé la question rien net
quels sont les qualités requises pour
être un bon détecteur de talent avant
tout je dirais qu'il faut être animalier
il faut les comprendre le cheval inquiet
c'est pas marqué dans les livres allez
Patrick tu as une histoire particulière
avec canette vous avez beaucoup
d'aventures ensemble des émotions en
particulier comment vous faites pour
gérer émotionnellement tout ça contre
doctrine elle est simple c'est toujours
travailler en osmose avec le cheval en
ayant nos objectifs et en essayant de
transmettre merci je pense que tu dois
t'occuper encore de renaître on va la
rentrer sur la musique de Lucky Luke